hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we have a fun
interdisciplinary episode looking at the
area where music meets neuroscience
we've had a little bit of music we've
had Wynton Marsalis after all quite a
bit of neuroscience but we've never
looked at this particular issue teaming
them up how we learn about music and how
music helps us learn how it changes us
as people
today's guest andreas Cantus is a PhD
neuroscientist and she still does neuro
scientific research but her main focus
has become music she's an opera singer
someone who gets up there and belt out
the arias on stage and also someone who
creates new musical projects she's the
creative director of the Pasadena opera
for example so it's very natural that
she would address this question of how
musical influence changes what's going
on in our brain and also how what's
going on in our brain creates different
kinds of music how it inspires us to do
different things her most recent book is
called how music can make you better
the idea being that in various ways not
only do we learn music but music helps
us learn other things helps us train our
minds helps us be sociable and even can
have therapeutic uses so it's been a lot
of fun to learn about this while reading
the book and talking within drea on the
podcast cuz neuroscience you know is one
of those things where we learn a lot
there's been enormous progress in recent
years and months there's constantly new
neuro scientific discoveries coming down
the pike but there's so much that we
don't know it's so easy to ask a
question in neuroscience to which we
don't know the answer so we'll both do
that we'll hear some of the fun new
results have been coming out but also
point at a lot of areas where we don't
exactly know what music in the brain are
doing with each other one way or the
other I should also mention that in Drey
has her own podcasts two of them in fact
one is called inquiring minds which I've
appeared on the other is a new one
called cadence which is specifically
about music and the mine here at the
mindscape podcast we have the news that
we're going to be joining the Wonder II
podcast network there the folks will be
giving us the ads to eventually play
here on the podcast episodes so if you
want to tell Wonder E a little bit about
the demographics of mindscape listeners
you're welcome to go to Wonder EECOM
slash survey
I look for a little button that says
Sean Carroll's mindscape and tell them a
little bit about yourself that will help
them decide what kinds of ads we should
have on here that's wandering calm slash
survey and with that this is going to be
a very fun episode so let's go
[Music]
in drapes contest welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks so much for
having me
so I'm sure you've heard this before but
you have a more unusual than most job
description splitting your time between
being a neuroscientist and being an
opera singer and and generally sort of a
musical person as well as having a whole
separate outreach component in fact
let's let me be a good podcast host and
let you plug your own podcast that you
add sure I actually have two now the one
that is weekly is called inquiring minds
and that's a sort of broad view of
science and society we say where science
and society collide and then I launched
a couple years ago a podcast called
cadence what music tells us about the
mind which has had two seasons come out
it's much more produced the seasons are
eight to ten episodes and it was
actually the inspiration for a book that
I think hopefully we will talk about
today we might you might talk about the
book yet and so I'm working on the third
season now which is gonna be about how
music influences us which I'm really
excited about um so hopefully we've
we're about halfway through having
recorded the interviews so hopefully
that'll come out you know in a few weeks
okay that's fantastic but neuroscience
you got a PhD in neuroscience you're
still practicing research yeah the kind
of research I do now is much more kind
of Applied Research that I find
interesting that I think might help me
become a better performer or me become a
better teacher or somehow that I could
do that nobody else can do rather than
you know having a big lab where I'm
running subjects all the time no that's
a you quickly become an administrator
and it's a full-time job yeah exactly so
I don't do that but I'll tell you about
one study that I'm kind of excited about
so you know I've recently gotten
interested in how technology can change
our minds and can help us become more
efficient if not less efficient as in
the case of most technology it seems
makes us less efficient as we try to
multitask and so you know I was really
skeptical of this idea that you could
stimulate your brain into becoming a
better pianist oh yeah if you've seen
some of these ads there's a company
called halo neuroscience that made this
headset that's commercially available
and it's you know transcranial direct
stimulation and it's supposed to
essentially stimuli
motor cortex put it into what they call
a hyperplastic mode which means it's
kind of more open to change and then you
practice your instrument or you you know
work on some kind of athletic skill and
that's supposed to increase the efficacy
with which you can you know train and so
we're examining that we're trying to see
whether that's true for our students at
the conservatory of music so highly
motivated professional grade musicians
and you know so that's the kind of
research I do now
like like is this really something that
might actually work and if it does work
are there protocols that you know we
should think about that would make it
most effective so the music and the
neuroscience for you are not two
separate things you're doing a thing and
part of that things neuroscience and
part of music is that fair yes totally
fair I mean you know I'm really
interested in how the brain changes
overall even my PhD was about
neuroplasticity and and to me music is a
kind of really great model of
neuroplasticity because we can easily
measure changes that happen with
training even you know single exposures
to music can leave their signatures in
their brain just like virtually any
other experience that is immersive in
some way so that's interesting to me as
a model but more so you know music to me
is a really powerful way of looking at
what it means to be human because it's
so bizarre like why is it that we you
know we can we can fall in love over
music we can incite hate over music I
mean people get killed because they play
the wrong rap song you know or you know
perform the wrong rap song and so why
it's so stupid
ultimately and compressions of air you
know it's even Pinker will argue is
totally meaningless you know language is
much more important and yet you know
it's it's pretty hard to kill somebody
with words not that it's easy to kill
somebody with music but it does seem to
really powerfully incite people to
behave in ways that they might not
otherwise there's something visceral
about it yeah there's some connection
and so I do want to get into where that
comes from but but first it's not just
that you like music and study it you do
it so let's fill in the audience what it
means when I say that you do music sure
so you know forever since I can remember
I was a singer
when I was a kid I grew up in choirs and
then I started doing opera and even
during my graduate work as a PhD student
in neuroscience I could maintained my
love of music and I would you know
scurry away every week for lessons and
coaching's and then the summers I'd you
know go off to Europe and perform a role
somewhere and you know some small
company or training program and so it's
always a part of me and then once I
graduated for my PhD I just realized
that I really needed to give it a shot
whatever that means
so I went and got a master's in music
and now I perform and I mean I you know
I would say that my performing life
maybe makes up a quarter or maybe ten
percent of my actual kind of
income-generating or kind of
project-based work but it's a really
important part of it and so now I kind
of do at least one or two big musical
performance projects a year and that
includes not just singing but a musical
director or something yeah so I'm the
creative director of a little company
that I founded with a friend of mine
Danis at Eva she's the artistic director
called Pasadena opera and we picked
Pasadena your bed yard for two reasons
one there is a big intellectual
community there and generally people who
are well educated tend to be more likely
to have been exposed to opera and
therefore like it and also there's a lot
of history of arts focus and Pasadena
and there's a kind of openness in the
community to sort of towards cultural
change and so we were really interested
in kind of like starting a company there
that would really be about putting on
opera that's accessible that's
interesting that's relevant and that
speaks to whatever's going on in the
community so how many operas have you
put on we've put on four and we're in
the midst of of putting on our fifth is
actually our first Commission so gaily
committed to supporting living composers
so we commissioned a new york-based
composer named Daniel felsenfeld to
write an opera based on a novel by a
feminist from the 70s named Angela
Carter she used to like she wrote these
retold fairy tales with feminist endings
and she was not she was kind of
forgotten in her time and she's and her
works have kind of resurfaced
interestingly through the semi-to
movement maybe but maybe just didn't you
know
feminism is always changing yeah anyway
so it's this retelling of the Bluebeard
Castle story which is this psychological
thriller where you have Bluebeard who's
some kind of big rich aristocrat
whatever you want to call him he brings
his new bride home and he says to her
you know you have access to this entire
house except that one room right and
it's a real metaphor for marriage you
know or partnership where like how much
like do you do you really let your whole
self be open to your partner or do you
keep a little bit to yourself maybe your
darkest part and of course she opens
that door because she can't help herself
and in it are all his dead wife as
things happen yes that's right yeah I
could watch TV come on I'm spoiling it
for you only because the ending is
different in the bloody chamber which is
what it's called so I'm really excited
to put that on and so that that's going
on in January of 2020 cool good we'll
watch out for that and when when you are
performing it's singing right I mean
yeah opera singing just the phrase comes
fro it's different than other kinds of
singing it looks hard the standards are
very high why did you pick the hardest
kind of singing there is to do yeah I
mean it is hard um to me it's it's the
only kind of singing where there and and
even these days kind of changing but
there shouldn't be any in my opinion
amplification so there should be nothing
separating the human voice from the
audience and that's why it sounds weird
because in order to project in a big
space you have to be able to make a lot
of noise but it still has to sound
pretty so so that's what we trained for
so many years to do to use our bone
structure or resonance or diaphragm or
lungs to be able to project sound as far
as it can possibly go but still sound
beautiful to me you know I kind of I
like I love the aesthetic abut I love
the sound because I grew up listening to
it so it's very comfortable for me but I
also just love the stories I mean operas
big spectacle yeah yeah I mean you don't
you know Seinfeld the Opera would be a
really tough sell it was the game of
thrones of its time yeah yeah well Game
of Thrones would make a great opera you
know I mean epic I think I mean you know
in some ways the vogner Ring cycle is
really mild version of Game of Thrones
but yeah so you know I think that that's
that's what appeals to me about it is
that is I have this this connection to
it
to me it's beautiful and it's
challenging and you know it's like
anybody who pursues any that ik thing
you know white people do gymnastics
that's really hard don't understand that
one either yeah but you know there's a
kind of euphoria that comes with doing
something hard and being able to do it
well and now you're coming out you've
come out with a book that combines your
passions for neuroscience and music what
is it the title yeah it's called how
music can make you better and and it's
kind of its left kind of an open
question mark because of course the
first thing better at what yes and the
answer is just better you know in many
different ways so the first is really
divided up into three sections the first
section is sort of how does your brain
turn sound into music and you know
essentially make sound better which to
me is really fascinating and the second
part is what people are more expecting
to hear which is can it actually heal my
brain or body and so I talk about
different ways that music is used in
medicine but also you know is it
effective in terms of a workout tool
that kind of thing and then finally I
turn to whether music can make society
better you know in my opinion that's
probably why it evolved the way it did
is because it's a powerful social glue
it helps us communicate when we don't
have language or in in communicate ideas
and acts and emotions that surpass
language and but you know it can also be
used in ways that are not so good to
incite violence to get people to you
know create tribes or groups you know
that then earn identify yeah fight songs
exactly so so those are the three sex
sections cool so that's good we have
time to get into this so let me just
start with even before we get to music
what about sounds like what do we know
about what happens when you hear
something what happens in the brain and
I actually know a little bit about the
visual process in the brain I know
nothing about how we perceive so yeah
because I feel like it's all physics
well I'm sorry just just a explain I was
when I was at University of Chicago I
was on the PhD thesis committee for some
students who were physics graduate
students but studying neuroscience of
the visual cortex
okay so here's something about that got
it got it got it so um so and by the way
like right at the top when you you know
it's like a it's a pot calling the
kettle black a little bit here Sean in
my opinion wrote one of the best books
about consciousness Oh written so so
yeah but um okay so let's start with
what sound is right so sound is just
rarefactions and compressions of air for
some reason our species has decided that
the way its samples sound is by turning
it into a perceptual experience that we
recognize as sound right or you know
this this sound waves I should say so
you know can we can imagine that this
could have been very different right
like the way a bat hears through
echolocation is probably very different
it's probably more like the visual
system yeah
and so so that that you know isn't is
kind of arbitrary part of the way that
we evolved is actually do we know if the
way that bats think about sound sort of
melds with the visual system differently
than doesn't human well I mean I would
imagine I don't know the answer that
question very deeply except to say that
if I were a bat and I was me because I
think of echolocation as a way of seeing
the world right because they use it to
navigate and to find things so there are
a couple of stories of one in particular
that I'm thinking of a kid named Ben
Underwood who when he was - do you know
the story had been underworld when he
was - he lost his eyes - to cancer and
he developed the ability to echolocate
so there are these amazing videos that
you can hear yeah watch an ad I do know
him yeah maybe I've been on stage with
him he clicks that's right and and
that's how he sees so unfortunately he
died but I don't know him I got someone
else who had to sing it okay so maybe
yeah so maybe there are others who do
this right say me it's really
fascinating and if you are one of these
people that does this please please
please reach out I really want to talk
to you about this I can get you in touch
with the guy who I was onstage with they
have a school there in LA
why able to echolocate oh so cool oh yes
now I have to go and see that because I
think that's the answer to our question
is like because what I mean what seems
to happen is that they repurpose their
visual cortex to use sound to
essentially navigate through the world
so I just wonder what that experience is
like for them yeah I mean do they
actually you know in their minds I see
the sound and and you know there's a
reason why Thomas Nagel famous pieces
what is it like to be a bad example
he's so different and that's why I chose
the bat analogy because because of that
exact exact piece and and you know so so
that's what I anyway so that he already
gets us down one rabbit hole so I don't
know what it's like to be a bat but I
imagine it's different from what it's
like for me to hear sound right and so
anyway so we've developed this ability
to somehow turn these sound waves into
something that we now perceive of is
sound we have you know a cochlea which
is the inner part of your ear that
essentially does this transduction right
it takes there's like literally a
fluid-filled structure that has all
these little hair cells and the hair
cells sway as the fluid moves to the
pattern of the sound wave that opens
these ion channels at the tips of the
cells which lets in essentially or
changes the membrane potential it
creates an electrical change which then
your brain you know you that's the
language of the brain right it almost
makes you sympathetic to intelligent
design when you hear these complicated
kinds of things but then you trace it
back in evolutionary time well has a
membrane in every cell exchanges ions
you know one cell just happened to turn
that into a different signal that also
releases chemicals and blah blah blah
yeah to me it's all like you know in
some ways even more evidence that this
is the process that you know is
something that that just happened over
these small little tweaks so anyway so
we have like 10,000 of these hair cells
or something like that
and so we can tell you know we can tell
different frequencies apart different
timbres you know and so forth now
imagine that you your cochlea does not
function and you're hard of hearing one
thing that we can do is we can implant a
cochlear implant for some of these
patients and restore hearing to a way
that is pretty remarkable so you know my
friend Charles Lim who's an ear surgeon
who does these this kind of work you
know he he argues that in fact we can
or hearing better than we can restore
any other sense but it's not nearly
perfect we can talk about now and and in
my understanding of the history of
cochlear implants
you know people kind of thought oh you
can just put like an electrode that you
know into the cochlea that kind of you
know but but the problem is is only
gonna have like maybe 10 to 20 leads you
know as opposed to 10,000 hair cells so
like and also then how are you gonna
teach the brain to like interpret this
signal you know and and my understanding
of the history is that you know they
really worried about this for a long
time and then finally some rogue ear
surgeon just put one in and it turns out
they didn't have to worry about it
because I actually yeah I was gonna
guess that I don't know about the
sensitivity in the 10 versus tens of
thousands but my impression from talking
neuroscientists is the brain figures out
how to do things exactly it's not just a
module that only does one thing it
figures it out yep it figures it out and
if the person is motivated enough to
continue to repeatedly try and
repeatedly you know listen in that way
and try to make sense of it then the
brain will help out so that's what
happens in these patients they
essentially learn to understand speech
which if you think about it as a really
complex sound right it's you know the
difference in a sound wave between two
words you know spoken by the same person
is so minimal yeah compared to all the
other sounds available right yet they're
able to do that they're able to you know
essentially you know able to understand
and and speak language they don't really
learn to appreciate music music still is
really that yes that like there's this
you know sometimes they give
descriptions like it sounds like broken
keys or it just sounds like noise I
interviewed this one guy who basically
has had a cochlear implant for a long
time and he was just like I don't
understand why anybody would pay a
single dollar for a piece of music
what about was this people who were deaf
from birth yeah it doesn't really matter
it you know for the most part I mean
everybody is somewhat different yeah so
there are some people who who were great
music aficionados lost their hearing but
even for them in most cases the cochlear
implant does not restore their love of
music a person who like the gentleman I
was telling you about he he was hard of
hearing from a very early age
and he still doesn't you know so he
doesn't understand but anyway one of my
little research projects with Charles
Lim actually was to create a choir of
people who are hard of hearing most of
whom had cochlear implants in order to
give them the motivation to spend the
same kind of energy parsing music as
they might you know parsing speech and
we sort of had these iPads in front of
them where they could see their voice
spectrograph like they actually see the
sound that they were making and we had
the pitches colored in different colors
and so like you know in order to you
know we're like okay everybody's singing
an a here's what it sounds like on the
piano we don't know what it sounds like
for them in there with their cochlear
implants but then you know we can we can
say it's got to be green on your iPad so
make noise until it's green and so
anyway so we kind of that you know kind
of work I do but um but this is a long
preamble to say essentially that
ultimately how we interpret sound as
music depends on our brains oh yeah and
and and it's you know high up in there
and so you know you're if you're not
like opera it's probably because you
haven't listened to it enough you know
or or it's just not interesting to you
I'm not saying that everybody ultimately
has to like opera but but usually it
means that if there is a genre of music
that a lot of people really like and you
know and universally agreed upon good
piece of music and you just don't like
it
part of it might be because your brain
is not processing it in the same way
right it's not finding meaning in the
same way like my mom for example hates
rap she hates heavy metal and I think
it's because it just sounds like noise
to her I mean if you had you know if you
brought a chainsaw into the room I would
find that annoying - but Metallica I get
it it's not that different right yeah so
how would you define music what is it
that separates music out from other
sounds yeah so um I think it depends on
every person's brain I think it's how
the ocean is how would you define it you
know and and that's why you know some
some things are music to some people and
not to others and even silence can be
music as you know some experimental
composers have demonstrated it's the
context that you bring in terms of how
you listen to the soundscape right so if
you're listening to the soundscape for
meaning that goes beyond you know the
speech or the kind of physical aspects
of the sound like where
located is it a bird or a car then I
would argue that it's music okay but in
the music that we know and love there
are certain properties right the
repetition versus variations yes exactly
in fact repetition is the one universal
feature of virtually every music that we
know of except the music that explicitly
avoids it which is like but that's kind
of post repetition right there doing a
just being ornery exactly and it's hard
to listen to and in fact if you if you
hack some of that music and add
repetition people will label it as more
interesting more enjoyable and more
likely to have been composed by human
beings a key feature of music and I
think that that's the reason that it is
is because that sort of sets the pattern
right so you can turn a simple sentence
into music by repeating it over and over
again you know add a beat add some other
kind of thing and all of a sudden you've
got a piece of music and that's because
I think the way that your brain you know
your brain habituates right so you you
polka you know California please yeah a
sea slug on its tail a bunch of times
eventually it stops withdrawing its tail
putting up it's not getting any new
information so if you are listening to a
repeated pattern you're going to search
for new information on it are you gonna
ignore it right so your refrigerator hum
probably doesn't have that much more
info so after living in your place for a
couple nights you ignore it you no
longer hear it but you know when it
comes to music great music in my opinion
has multiple layers of meanings that
your brain enjoys finding and and seeing
and you know we are ultimately as you
know you probably talked about better
than I can interested in the search for
meaning
isn't that right yeah when into physics
yes meaning it understands it yeah yeah
meaning and understanding so it's the
same thing I think in terms of music
especially when that meaning and
understanding tells us something really
authentic about humanity so there's this
great quote by Harlan about country
music so country music is three chords
and the truth like you know even if you
don't like country music like that you
know it gives me chills thinking about
that's true there's the hard part yeah
the hard part but it's exactly right
like great music tells you something
truthful that you
get in any other medium yeah with
whether or not there are words yeah
we're transcend the sort of literal
meaning of the words I mean so you
mentioned I just now had this thought
you mentioned that repetition rhythm in
some sense is universal and how music
gets done everywhere is melody universal
yeah
so I mean yeah so the to I guess the two
main components of music are rhythm and
melody right so I think most people will
argue that the vast majority of music
out there has these two components and
you know I think that again I think it
depends on exactly how you define melody
and I'm sure you can have a music music
ologist too well you know talk about
that for three hours I'm not that person
except to say I think of it as a line
that is recognizable that you know
sometimes it's repeated sometimes it's
not but you know has a kind of you know
phrase quality to it there's a beginning
a middle and an end to a melody and you
know it's it's it's recognizable as a
line and that kind of speaks to the fact
that music is something that happens
over time time is crucially important
usually important right and and and so
you know music is there in the moment
and and and it kind of unfolds over time
and the melody is kind of what is that
is the person taking the journey whereas
the rhythm is the one that's setting the
timescale yeah okay that makes sense so
since um you're just parking my brain
with all these questions that I've never
thought of before is there an
explanation for why traditionally music
likes to pick a certain discrete set of
notes rather than just have you know if
you had a violin you just buy any note
you wanted to right but we agree ahead
of time these are the notes you're
supposed to play the major scale or
something like that sure and I think
that's because it allows us a kind of
boundary or framework for where we're
gonna find these patterns and where
we're gonna extract the meaning with
repetition if there's only a finite
number of choices to pay great that's
right that's right and and also you know
different genres will have different
rules right whether it's jazz or rap or
hip-hop or classical music depending on
the era it will have different rules of
tonality so how much can you deviate
from you know the particular established
tones right so a lot of the really great
composers like Beethoven for example was
like scandalously deviant Lily yeah
I'm yeah and yet we listen to it as you
know seems so pleasant and and you know
almost uptight
it's like rule-based structure so I
think that you know in order for you to
know and and predict where the music is
gonna go there has to be a kind of
understanding of what the rules are so
you know the examples that I sometimes
give is is jazz so if you if you never
listen to jazz then you probably
gravitate towards relatively simple
riffs and melodies that is easily
recognizable to you you know you know
where the melody is and you can kind of
predict where it's gonna go and you know
it might surprise you a little bit but
it's not totally shocking now if you're
a jazz aficionado
smooth jazz which is a lot of this it's
you just rolled your eyes it's
excruciating because it's far too simple
it's mind-numbing ly boring in that
sense because there's nothing
interesting about it it's like you know
eating white bread so so I think that
you know that that means that you listen
to it differently because so then when
you when you listen to a really great
jazz player and you know they're playing
my funny Valentine for example or some
other really famous melody but you like
barely recognize the melody in it but
you know where it's going in it all kind
of fits in it's like this magical puzzle
that you're yeah you know listening to
and it's really great so so yeah so I
think that again I think it depends on
your genre and depends on within the
genre how you know how old the genre is
how much it has these established rules
how much composers have had to push
against these rules to create something
new and so on and all this is to say
that it harnesses what I think of as the
brains you know fundamental trait which
is it wants to predict the future Yeah
right like our memories not about the
past it's about giving us the ability to
create a potential future and see
whether our behavior is gonna make us
survive or kill us right so um that's
really what ultimately music does it
harnesses the brains desire to predict
the future and so you know you create
tension as a musician for an ultimate
release if you stop the piece before the
tension is released I mean unless that's
really an internal write it's annoying
or it's an intentional choice in which
case you've annoyed your audience and
that's your art right so I think that
that's kind of you know what we have to
be able to give our listeners enough
information about what their what the
future is gonna hold for them
and then as great musicians we know that
we can push and pull against that to
tell them something truthful or
interesting do you know about the
Bayesian brain hypothesis have you heard
of that I mean I know about Bayes
theorem so yeah tell me more about the
Bayesian brain I bought this is uh Carl
Freeston who apparently is a famous
neuroscientist
oh yeah exactly so he's a little funny
because he you know got a very famous
and a billion citations etc for imaging
yeah but now his whole thing is this
grand unified theory of the brain called
the free energy principle or the
Bayesian brain hypothesis and it's
basically a form of a formalization of
exactly what you said all the brain
tries to do is predict the future so
it's called Bayesian because you're
constantly updating when you get new
information in and you're trying to
minimize the surprise that's what
happens and he tries to you know it's
very controversial some people love it
some people hate it lots of people say I
would love it but I don't understand
what he's saying but it's probably too
simple to be exactly true but I think
it's probably something true about it
yeah and I think it's actually really
important from a neuroscience
perspective to put it out there like
that I mean I know that takes a lot of
courage especially nowadays as you know
anyway we have access to so much more
information that it seemed like we did
30 years ago but yeah I mean I I
probably would endorse a lot of that
particular idea well so you mentioned
the difference between you know
simplistic pop song and oat ray jazz
improvisation you also mentioned in the
book that there are two points in a
person's life when they are especially
susceptible to learning and being
impressed by music right yeah yeah when
you're kids yeah exactly and I and I
almost think like that in some ways
maybe you know yeah of course as you
know you write a book and then a bunch
of time goes by and then it comes out
and so you're like man I wish I had
written that you know it really is like
about you know the early period is like
early childhood is essentially when
you're auditory cortex is developing is
when your brain is learning to process
sound so kids who are trained as
musicians early on like their brains
literally react to sound differently
even if they stop playing piano or stop
learning their instruments many many
years later we can still see the kind of
quote-unquote musicians signature
something was wired in
something was wired in there and and you
know so you take a kid who's exposed to
a lot of extraneous noise who has to
actually tune it out then your your
their relationship with sound is going
to be different and in fact some of
these kids who grow up in urban
environments who you know generally are
more likely to be low-income because
they're exposed to a lot of noise that
can't be tuned out they sometimes have
trouble with language skills later on in
life because they're just not hearing
like they have trouble parsing speech
out of noise so you can imagine that
that's a problematic thing and and if
you teach them to play musical
instrument you can actually undo some of
this damage huh because what you're
doing is essentially retraining their
brain to process sound differently to
have this different neural signature
when it comes to a sound stimulus or a
sound wave so that's the early period so
that's kind of like then nuts and bolts
of it and that sorry that is when we
like the most simple and repetitive
stuff right yes seals on the bus go
round exactly exactly exactly and part
of that is because you know the kid is
trying to figure out you know he likes
to you know prick the future do ya why
these kids like these songs that never
hand really there's a Calvin and Hobbes
cartoon that says yo Calvin is grumpy he
clearly just got operated by his mom he
says I think if the novelty Christmas
song is funny once it's funny the
thousandth time olia logical why isn't
it time well they'll learn but you know
I think that the second period is where
what I think of more is kind of the
emotional you know the part of your life
that you always return to nostalgic ly
through music it's the part of your life
where you know your your brain your
prefrontal cortex which is the last part
of your brain to develop and wire up
essentially that's when it's being
myelinated right when there's these this
fatty sheath that is going is wrapping
itself around the connections between
neurons to make them faster and more
efficient and you know the front part of
your brain is you know where you do a
lot of complex decision-making emotional
regulations so no social interactions
he's kind of like higher higher level
cognitive and human traits so that's all
developing in your late teens and even
into your early 20s so tell me more
about the
yeah so myelination is essentially one
of the reasons that we have the brains
that we do is because we as mammals and
vertebrates have developed the ability
to make our axons more efficient right
so the axon is the part of the cell that
takes information from the cell body
from the dendrites and sends it down
you know it's it's wire essentially and
then lets out information on the other
end right so in order to be able to
cross large swaths of brain or to go
from your spinal cord to your big toe
we need that signal to be really fast so
one of the ways that the nervous system
has evolved to make it faster is by
myelinating essentially covering it with
a fatty sheath like think about it
insulating a wire right so the
electrical changes don't bleed out all
the way down the action potential just
you know propagates all you know
essentially it jumps it's called
saltatory conduction so you can think of
it it's like you know you've got a bus
in your local town it can make a stop at
every single stop sign which makes it
really slow
more people have to get in and out or
you can have the rapid bus that you know
is the express right so myelin creates
express buses out of our axons does it
happen to every axon or is it the most
important ever saying every and but the
vast majority huh you get to be a
teenager before that happens you have to
be a teenager before that happens in the
prefrontal cortex so the rest of the
brain is happening earlier on and and
this has actually one of the reasons why
it seems that maybe people who
ultimately develop schizophrenia have
their first psychotic breaks or their
first disorganized thinking episodes
around their early 20s late teens
because as as the healthy teenage brain
or neuro typical teenage brain is
myelinating up and you're becoming more
rational and you're able to control your
emotions the brain of a person with
schizophrenia is not myelinating in the
same way and so their thoughts become
disorganized they start to you know have
these other experiences so yeah so so
myelination of the prefrontal cortex
seems to be what is happening during
these late teenagers this worries me
into thinking that there's something
that freezes up
you when you're a teenager did I mean a
lot of people argue that some of your
personality traits do get formed there
although there's this really interesting
now kind of movement in personality
psychology to question that like do we
actually change pretty substantially in
terms of a person as we get older but
but yes that's that's the traditional
model is that you know you're you're
developing you're a lot of your a lot of
the weight your habits of thinking I
should say in this time period okay so
your myelinating but you also have
raging hormones you're going through
puberty yep and you're listening it
Tunes with your friends yes because you
have a push to separate from your
parents right there's this I mean it's
it's better for you to go off and you
know have sex with people who are not
genetically related to you you need to
leave the family mess yes so there seems
to be this you know the kind of
rebellious part of our nature that that
comes online here which you could
imagine is actually very evolutionarily
adaptive and so one but but we don't
like to be alone right we don't want to
feel isolated especially when we're
having this these big emotions and you
know we can't regulate them yet and you
know there's all these things that every
time everything's you know self-esteem
is coming into play but we're pimply and
gangly and everything right I don't know
why there are people who think that
those were the good times in their lives
yeah so so one thing that that's great
about music is that it's a powerful
social glue so when you listen when you
when you bounce in sync with someone
else to music you actually raise levels
of an attachment hormone called oxytocin
in both of your brains and that makes
you feel more bonded so there are some
like clever little experiments where you
know you'd have people bouncing in sync
with each other to a particular piece of
music or in sync with the experimenter
and then you know that the experiment
finishes and thank you very much and you
know here's the debriefing she told let
me just walk you to the elevator and on
the way to the elevator you drop a
pencil how likely is the person to pick
it up huh turns out that if you bounced
and sink much more likely it's and it's
been reproduced in toddlers well
nonetheless so toddlers will also be
more likely to help and accidentally
dropped toy if they were bounced in sink
by the adult or by the adults friend
but not if there's a neutral person in
the room that seems to be a stranger so
there does seem to be some kind of
attachment that happens where you tend
to then associate the person that you
were in sync with literally physically
as part of your tribe and people who are
out of sync with as another tribe I
wonder if mirror neurons has something
to do with it I mean for sure for sure
or at least the mirror neuron system you
know this idea that in our brains we
mirror the activity of the brains of the
person that we're watching as they
perform some goal directed activity
right so so there's there's that that in
there you know it's related to empathy
but you know you know this this kind of
synchronization in fostered by more
oxytocin this is all pro-social bonding
stuff right so you know people sometimes
think about oxytocin as the love hormone
right
it's it's not just you know it's much
more accurate to say it's the attachment
hormone because it's also the hate
hormone right so you actually feel more
aggression towards people you deem as
threatening your tribe or outside of
your tribe when you're high when you're
high on oxytocin I had Patricia
Churchland on the podcast recently in
the same message like oxytocin very very
important but more is going on than you
might way more I still I'm gonna call it
the cuddle molecule just because that's
an irresistible name sorry yeah I mean
you know you you still might be
skeptical well oh you know how much ever
well if you know you can snort oxytocin
now or you can like you have these
oxytocin though there's a nasal sprays
and if you there's a study that I really
like where if you spray people with this
or give them this oxytocin nasal spray
they actually keep the rhythm better it
like gives them rhythm rhythm alright
you think about like what what it means
to be in sync with someone that it seems
like that would make sense i alright the
synchronization well is it this is
connecting a whole bunch of different
podcast topics they talked to Steven
Strogatz about synchronization oh yeah
in different animal systems Wow
okay so yeah and so but but this story
helps explain why wheeler we always have
a special attachment to the tunes that
we really fell in love with when we were
teenagers yeah even if we look back and
with a slightly more jaundiced eye we
say well I get that that's not the best
song ever
but it's my song that's right I mean
it's still
we'll see the first time you hear it
again after a while it still gives you
this rush of nostalgia this rush of
feeling you know this rush of of kind of
security that you probably found in the
music that you love because you you know
it helped you find yourself in your
tribe but you're exactly right that we
can recognize that it's actually not
objectively good music and still have
this good effect what's interesting that
is that I feel like we actually tire of
it more quickly though so like imagine
that you you have like what's your
favorite song from when you were a
teenager early twenties can you name one
or like a favorite band yeah I can name
a bunch let me name yes yes okay now
let's say you spent all day listening to
yes
how soon would you start getting sick of
it well so here's the thing the reason
why I named yes is because fairly
recently I I don't know why but like i
redownload it an album that they came
out with when I was in college yeah
I started listening to it and I cannot
get that thing out of my head anymore
like it is embedded now and you reading
your book baby think about that oh great
yeah so sadly apparently I can listen to
it again and again and not quite as
elevated like I feel like in my
experience at least anyway and I don't
have any science to back this up but it
seems that you know yes those when you
hear them again for the first time it
feels great it feels like you're you're
finding your own teenage self again
which is really encouraging if you're
not that close to your teenage years
anymore but I also find that you know
you get I get bored more quickly
well you certainly want to move on but
you also mentioned the idea of the ear
worm right like sometimes we really find
it difficult to move on from a melody
that is stuck in our head yeah and and
you know I think there are certain
characteristics with melodies that make
them more likely to be stuck in their
heads and things like baby shark or
wheels on the bus have this problem
where they're never-ending it's like
right there's no resolution and so your
brain is like oh yeah I got that in my
head now and then it just keeps looping
especially if you're not paying very
close attention to it so like one of the
cures for ear worms is to in your head
like volitionally make up a big ending
how to put a big finish onto the piece
like work it through and then hopefully
your brain to be like okay now that's
done I can move on but if that doesn't
work and this is
really troubling to you it turns out
that medicines that are used for people
with obsessive-compulsive disorder can
be effective in getting rid of you know
the most severe types of ear worms and
that's because it's essentially it
becomes a little bit of an obsession
right yeah and and we see an overactive
caudate nucleus which is a nucleus in
your brain that is part of the kind of
goal directed motivated learning system
you have to explain that it's not my
kind of nucleus an atomic nucleus using
the word nucleus to mean something
different yes yes yes no I guess I
forget that a nucleus is a group of cell
bodies in the brain okay good and the
caudate nucleus would have caudate
nucleus so yeah it's part of the reward
system and essentially we can you think
of it as the wanting part of the brain
so in the anticipation of something
pleasurable or actually something awful
you can see more dopamine activity in
the caudate nucleus and and the caudate
nucleus is is also like if you lesion it
then animals have a hard time learning
you know new kind of habits and skills
okay so patients with Parkinson's
disease for example or Huntington's
disease have have less dopamine in the
brain and the credit is affected and and
anyway so they have habit learning
problems so so the caudate really and
when it comes to music we see it active
during the building up of tension part
of a musical phrase and then once you
get the release of tension if you get
the chills maybe or you know some other
kind of you know reaction we see a big
spike in dopamine in the nucleus
accumbens which is you know we love the
liking part of the brain so if the
caudate is the wanting part of the brain
the nucleus accumbens is the liking part
of the brain right so what actually
gives you the sense of pleasure as
opposed to the pursuit of pleasure so
anyway the caudate is is really
fascinating because it's been implicated
in a lot of human behaviors that are
hard to understand like for example
people who have anorexia we think now it
might be partly to do with a habit of
not eating so that they find eating
aversive and we see an overactive
caudate and in the sense that so it's
not just the desire to be thin
it's just that eating is unpleasant it's
it becomes a habitually unpleasant and
the worst thing that you can do is
force-feed a person with anorexia
because then you give them a really
immersive experience you're associating
misery with either even more right right
so um and the con it is a part about
it's sort of tracking the aspects of the
world that will lead to good things or
bad things but regardless things that
are important emotionally so this is
also why a lot of people who overdose
tend to do so in novel environments like
hotel rooms because your brain I know
it's like that having to connect the
dots you know your brain expects drug if
you take it in the same place at the
same time and so it it it's an
interested in maintaining homeostasis so
it swings in the other direction so
let's take you let's say you take a drug
that makes you feel you know down like
benzodiazepines right they actually
inhibit brain activity they sedate you
get rid of your anxiety now let's say
you take a lot of these drugs you have
to take more and more of them to get the
effect because your brain is expecting
them right it's trying to predict the
future so it's giving you actually you
know more anxiety more stress more you
know activity so that you need more the
drug to get back down now let's say you
go into a novel environment you take the
same dose of the drugs you've been
taking in your old environment but your
brain is not prepared for it that's when
you overdose right so the same exact you
know amount can now be fatal and that's
because you're caught it was not
prepared right but in the other
locations your caudate is trying to
figure out what is it about this
environment that's gonna cause this good
thing to happen I'm just telling now I'm
sort of surprised that led Zeppelin
could ever write stairway to heaven
without knowing all this neuroscience
right like they accurately manipulated
the caudate nuclei how all their
audience man yes exactly
know this you know I mean they know that
in order to have a great piece of music
you need to delay the release of tension
as as long as possible you know the
longer you extend the desire for the
pleasure the greater the pleasure when
it comes and pleasure is the death of
desire right so yeah and there's some
trade-off you can't extend it too long
or well yeah people will get frustrated
exactly so I want to talk about music
and learning
and this sort of has two sides to it
right one is that we learn music right
so yeah we
what is the neuroscience of how we learn
music let me just mention one fact that
I read in your book which I thought was
absolutely fascinating the musician
certain musicians play their instruments
so much that when they're playing you
know two of their fingers always move in
the same way in synchrony together and
their brain begins to forget that there
are two separate fingers there really
maps and I always heard that the other
way around you know how the brain can
sort of remap extra parts but I had
never thought about the brain forgetting
that there's a part there yeah this is
the dark side of neuroplasticity it's
called focal dystonia
so essentially where you have you know a
particular body part which now you know
your brain has trouble decoupling you
know that this particular and and we're
still learning exactly how this works
but the idea for I think I think that's
that's gaining traction is that in some
musicians like you perform the same
pattern over and over again or you train
your your hands to sort of be in sync in
a certain way and then all of a sudden
your brain actually remaps your
somatosensory cortex as that being you
know just as you said one finger rather
than two fingers and so now it's very
hard for you to decouple them and play
them one at a time and it becomes
actually a problem and you know you can
develop musicians cramp you know these
other kind of really really painful
annoying conditions the penis would
never get this because their fingers are
doing different things but what kind of
there are pianists who have gotten it
but but I think they're yeah mainly it's
I've seen it in guitarists wind
instruments but but yes you can get it
in piano although it might sort of look
a little bit different where it's not
just maybe the fingers that may be a
part of the palm and a finger you know
or what you have that that kind of
mapping or just you know some other kind
of mapping gone awry basically and and
but yeah like I you know I had a student
for whom it was the pinky finger and the
ring finger that got associated she was
a clarinetist okay and so you know she
did play and and so then you know she
had all these consequences where you
know she would get nervous and they
would start shaking and like there's
this it's this kind of these yeah these
kind of neurological things
you think you sit there and you think
fingers do your thing that's really
annoying it's brain brain do your thing
right and so so it's this painstaking
then kind of rehabilitation period where
you have to retrain your brain to kind
of you know map it differently again and
how much of learning to be a musician is
subconscious in some way or how much is
cognitive yeah so I mean I I you know
it's like it's a just like music playing
an inch to musical instrument or singing
it you know it has so many complex
different sub skills I would say it's
hard to sort of say that kind of in a
blanket statement there's lots of
conscious aspects of music making you
know the interpretation the music
reading if that's what you're doing etc
but in terms of just the pure motor
skill I like to think of there's this
kind of three-stage model by a guy named
Fitz that I like where you know things
kind of start clumsy and cognitive like
when your teacher tells you okay you got
to hold the your bow arm has to be you
know in this direction I could keep your
elbow up or whatever you've actually to
literally sit there and think about it
yeah it doesn't feel natural doesn't
feel natural you have to and in order to
do it you have to consciously say okay
arm lift up right over time over
multiple repetitions you start to
associate okay when I'm gonna pick up
the bow I'm gonna do this sequence of
movements right and so that's called the
associative stage where it's becoming a
you're essentially what you're doing is
you're automating parts of the motor
sequence but you still usually have to
think about how to implement them so
another example is driving stick shift
learning the drive stick shift right at
the beginning you're like what do you
mean you know first year second year
third year clutch you know and then
eventually you're like okay every time I
shift gears I have to put the clutch
down I get that but then it's like you
have to put it all together
and then eventually you get to the
automatic stage where it's now implicit
and in fact if you start thinking about
it too much you can actually interfere
with your ability to do the task right
and this is because what's happened in
your brain is that you've gone from what
we call sort of explicit or a
declarative memory version of the task
where you're actually thinking
consciously to a non declarative or
implicit performance of the task where
you know and these two systems can
compete with each other for your
cognitive resources so you know you you
you know you don't want to interfere
with your implicit learn
if you can avoid it but then eventually
if you become really good at what you're
doing like you know I gave the example
of Tiger Woods who in the middle of a
golf swing he can check his swing and
and readjust if he needs to even though
a lot of is very automatic that's sort
of bringing consciousness back oh she's
a higher level of conscious yeah yeah so
like you have yo-yo ma playing a cello
suite and somebody in the audience
coughs right like he can you know it
probably doesn't bother him at all or or
you know there's some kind of breeze
that happens or one of his strings
breaks or what-have-you you know he can
adjust we're using on the fly because
he's so good at what he does interesting
and is it true that we get worse at
learning how to play music as we get
older haha
so um you know I think I think we still
have the same expectations of things
happening quickly as we get older we
often don't spend the same amount of
time doing things as we get older you
know what I mean
I've long suspected that people
exaggerate the difficulty learning
things as you're older just because they
don't remember how much work it was
that's right in which they've pitted you
know young kids against you know
college-age adults like in a motor
tapping task for example the college
students do better quickly you know to
take some fewer tries what about 50 year
olds I don't I don't I mean I know
there's this Gary Marcus book guitar
zero where he documents his own journey
through this and and I have to disagree
with him in a lot of parts of this book
because I just don't believe that the
way that he was approaching sort of the
deliberate practice component is gonna
be the same as somebody who's devoting
all's I mean I know he spent a year
learning play the guitar and so forth
but you know it's a year like you know
any college student in my music program
like in their first year they're like
barely surviving right it's by their
fourth year of doing this every single
day with feedback with training that
they start to make serious gains so I
think it's it's an unreasonable
expectation that we can learn something
very quickly as we get older without
putting the same kind of time so you're
trying to offer hope with those of us
beyond our hormonal teenage years yeah
yeah I mean if you can if you really can
- but I mean let's let's just don't have
the time and the money to devote what we
need to do but if you have
that there's I don't think there's any
reason why you shouldn't be able to you
know do something really exceptional
with an instrument is there people
talked about the relationship of that
question to the question of learning new
languages I know that there's been at
least some studies that say it really is
harder to learn languages yeah so I mean
and part of that is because you know you
do have this sensitive period and
language learning where the way that
your brain processes language is
different if you're five and then if
you're 55 it really is learning a second
language we see it mapping on
differently in the 55 year old brain
compared with in the five year old brain
the same is actually true for learning
perfect pitch interestingly there is a
singer came out of Japan that looked at
kids who are between the ages of two and
four and a hundred percent of them they
finished this training protocol had
absolute or perfect pitch same with
perfect pitches pitches where like I
sing any note and you can tell me
exactly exactly right yeah we're like a
bus rumbles by and you can tell mewhat
noted it's playing quote-unquote so
that's perfect pitch in neuroscience
parlance we call it absolute pitch
because what is perfect mean right sure
so so these kids you know hundred
percent of them and you know ended up
getting absolute pitch and and and
that's because the way that they process
sound is different and when they're in
that sensitive period they can extract
regularities differently than when they
get older and they listen to it
differently as their auditory cortex
matures so I think you're gonna see some
similarities in language right that's
why kids who learn languages early don't
necessarily speak with an accent because
the way their brain processes that sound
is different so so there's probably some
elements of that but music you know
again like you know it's so subjective
like it do you really want to be a
perfect player you know as a musician
well you know it's better than being
what I am but you also have a reason for
why you want to play like the
six-year-old who's playing piano is
probably doing it because their parents
told them to that's right and you you
make the point that you can even learn
to sing well more than most people think
we I think most people probably think
that there are good singers out there
and less good singers and you argue that
it's more about training in practice and
and knowing what you're doing than most
people think
yeah
we see the differences in the brains of
singers as they've you know and
songbirds and you know other other
species that have this you know unique
ability to vocalize in many different
ways we see the brain changes so you got
to wire it up differently but that takes
time and I think one of the things that
is really hard is that for a lot of
people awkward singing is really
embarrassing oh yeah right
you know so they don't so it's the
auction to this whole emotional thing
that makes it you know so if you're if
you're trying to sing and you're having
such a big emotional reaction your brain
is gonna be like first of all that I
don't want do that again we'll do that
or it's gonna be like focusing on one of
the aspects of the emotion not on the
content of the information that you're
getting right so so I think because our
voices are such a reflection of who we
are as people it can be something that's
really it's hard to be objective and
just say I'm just gonna keep training on
this until I get it right
but you can learn I remember an
interview with Lady gaga yes where the
interviewer was asking about the fact
that when she was young she was in a Led
Zeppelin cover band belting out you know
rock and roll and misty mountain hop and
so they said doesn't that hurt your
throat if you sing that all night long
and she's like not if you know how to
sing that's right not if you know how to
do it exactly and so you know yeah when
opera singers try to sing musical
theater without knowing what they're
doing they will hurt themselves even
though they have this like you know
apparently really great technique but
you know musical theater singers who
then turn around and try to sing opera
again it can hurt themselves but if they
but not if they're doing what they've
been trained to do can you pinpoint what
the difference is between singing and
musical theatre and singing in Opera
yeah I mean you know in a nutshell it's
the sort of belting so essentially it's
where you're putting most of your
tambour and remember the musical theater
you're largely amplified so you don't
have to project as much and so you know
the weight essentially the way that you
how much pressure you put through your
vocal cords and and and that is
different right you know okay put it
down to that you know the way you use
your resonance and and the way you the
way you control your breath is gonna be
slightly different and what about the
other way around we can learn music and
there's the claim that music helps us
learn there's the Mozart Effect right
and this was
actually based on something scientific
and then it got a little bit out of
control
yeah I mean something scientific in the
sense that it was like literally one a
one-page paper from 1993 from UC Irvine
politics yeah of like you know 30
undergraduates and what it was is is
people had you know that the scientists
had had three conditions they had these
undergraduates perform ultimately a
bunch of the IQ test the sub tests like
the spatial reasoning
you know sub tests you know we're like
you here's that here's a picture of a
geometric shape here are some blocks you
know make the blocks look like the
picture that kind of thing so they had
three conditions the first condition was
where they played Mozart's Piano Sonata
I believe and for fifteen minutes before
they were asked to do these tests or
they sat in silence or they listen to
relaxation tapes now which of those
three conditions do you think is more
arousing music they are probably
slightly more awake yep slightly more
indeed engaged and they perform better
slightly on these tests if you had given
them a shot of espresso or you know in
in subsequent replications of this kind
of work you know reading a Stephen King
chapter was just as arousing blur was
just as regressing and we're using
arousing just in the sense of heightened
senses oh yes I mean just more awake
right right I don't mean sexually right
okay yeah but but but certainly in terms
of just your general whether or not
you're awake or asleep your general
arousal level of your brain yeah so yeah
so so that was the original Mozart
effect and that led into this whole like
Baby Einstein like you know play music
for your baby it'll be give them better
IQ which most of it is is totally not
supported by the research but if you
look at sort of musical training there
is a relationship between the extent of
musical training and ultimately academic
success if that's really what you're
interested in or performance on IQ tests
which we all know are imperfect measure
of intelligence for them but what we see
is that kids who have three years or
more of individual music lessons tend to
show higher IQs or higher academic
achievement than kids who on average
don't have that kind of exposure now
you've got a confound here pretend
Julie of socioeconomic status because on
average kids that can afford to go to
have music lessons are gonna be on
average richer than kids who can't but
there are a couple of nice controlled
studies like there's one study in
particular in out of Boston Public
Schools where they you know randomly
assigned kids to two groups one was an
instrumental music group one was a kind
of just group music classes and and they
did start seeing changes in the brain
after only 15 months of musical training
that that map on to what we would have
expected now they didn't see changes in
IQ or changes in parts of the brain that
we think are really responsible for
higher intelligence but you know that's
because I think it just wasn't enough
time so so identical limitations of the
study get in the way at some point yeah
I mean I do think it's compelling you
know if you're only studying music to
make yourself smarter I think probably
you're gonna burn out eventually but I
think music is something that is an
enjoyable and stretches you and puts you
out of your comfort zone and and you
know one of the great statistics that I
love to quote is that it makes you more
likely to go to school so in in LA for
example there have been a number of
studies of kids who you know are at risk
who don't generally are not expected to
attend school very often if you put a
school music program and they're more
likely to could show up interest do they
want to play and they want to you know
play in the band yeah they like it it's
more fun to go to school now you know
you keep kids in school and off the
streets they're less likely to commit
crimes and end up in juvie or ultimately
in jail now you take one child and you
turn it around so they don't end up
going to jail that pays for ten years of
a music teacher salary right so yeah
yeah right so I think that in that sense
it can make us all smarter because it
can it can make us make school more
enjoyable it can make us attend to
school more and ultimately help Society
but that's learning an instrument or or
being trained in music we you said
earlier if I'm remembering correctly
that being exposed to classical music
when you're young will affect you later
in the sense it'll make you more likely
to appreciate classical music when
you're older yeah you're saying it
doesn't help you with any higher
cognitive capacities but maybe being
trained as a musician does yeah exactly
exactly I don't know that listening to
Mozart growing up is gonna make you
smarter I think that if you listen to
Mozart growing up you probably
have a you know family that has already
yeah the heredity and you know the SES
and it'll put you there I can't say that
that's that the actual listening to
music is a bigger factor than those
other huge factors yeah and then there's
a you know the final section of your
book which is fascinating about these
social aspects of music I mean you make
the point which is a good one but what
I'd never thought about that
most music is truly social unless you
are all by yourself performing a piece
of music that you wrote yourself right
right and even then you still have you
probably still have the idea that there
is a listener maybe somewhere you know
but yes I mean I was like truly trying
to see is there a ball with a head
written on it yeah so and and that plays
out in a million different ways I mean
the your book is about how music makes
the world better so how does how does
music in this sort of social aspect help
us make the world better well I think it
in the in the most simplest way I think
it engenders empathy I think it allows
us to put ourselves in someone else's
shoes to experience someone else's
humanity in a way that maybe we wouldn't
have in another medium and therefore you
know feel you know merciful towards them
or feel connected to them or in somehow
understand them a little bit better so
you know if you think about you know the
kind of music you know it gives people
an outlet like I sometimes I think about
like the turntable culture of the 1970s
and New York where you know this is
where this was a you know that this was
invented and it was invented because
people needed to get out of their homes
because you know they didn't really love
where they lived and they they wanted to
be you know social together they go out
into the streets and they'd have these
dance parties and they just wanted to
keep dancing and so they created this to
turntable technique where you know you
can essentially keep the rhythm going it
doesn't have to stop the song doesn't
end song song doesn't end right you can
keep dancing forever right and you know
and so anyway so and then and then you
add on to that spoken word and you know
an outlet for people to express
themselves and and so forth and so all
of a sudden you can see that how you
know that that this kind of genre of
music evolved out of a sense of you know
trying to engage with your community
trying to make your own situation better
and of course there's a flipside right
like we already said there are light
songs and fight songs can be good if
it's just you know my sports team
your sports team but there's also
martial music I mean there's you can
stir up the emotions of the populace
using music that's right exactly and you
know even in the book I mentioned bono
who is my favorite artist growing up you
basically not wanting to sing sunlight
Sunday Bloody Sunday because he was
worried he was gonna incite more
violence I mean this is like you know he
was genuinely worried about this are you
I don't think he is right I think that
there are times when you can exactly
stir up people's emotions enough where
they go out and then they riot I mean
you do the same thing with you know for
some reason sports ball game yes right
but I think part of I mean imagine a
sports event without music right right
like take all the you know chanting and
and you know music playing and all that
out of it and you still have the same
reaction I don't know well I mean it
goes I presume that there's a
long-standing relationship between
having a football gaming having a
marching band well yeah and even even
the taunts and the shouts and we will
you know whatever or like yeah yeah
Yankees suck what I the example I think
of when this topic comes up or
soundtracks for movies and TV right
which always which are brilliant and
important and a little manipulative I
feel like the psycho scene with like you
know pleasant you know the wheels on the
bus I mean how much have we studied the
neuroscience of that either
it's be more and more studied and it's
fastly now because now we have in in
certain places these kind of theaters
that are built to study people's
physiology while they're experiencing
you know concerts or films you know
where you can look at galvanic skin
response which is a measure of how
sweaty your palms are Brett breath rate
and rest you know respiration rate your
heart rate etc so we can actually see we
can track people's emotional at least
the physiology of their emotions as
they're looking at films or listening to
concerts and and and so yeah I mean what
you know it's essentially what you think
you we would find which is that these
things are very powerful and you can
look at different aspects of music
pacing
the types of instrumentation used etc
that can dictate what kinds of you know
expectations people will start to have
right like you have anonymous
ominous theme and and what you see is a
rowboat on a lake in this foggy but it
was a comp lesson you know kind of like
you're about to have spa day music then
you think oh that's just calming because
the brain wants to predict things a very
good clue for predicting exactly yeah
speaking of the neuroscience of it
forget about just sports or soundtracks
do composers know about the neuroscience
I mean I choked about Led Zeppelin
before I mean is that a frontier where
people are knowingly manipulating our
nuclei I mean I'm sure there are but I
also think that you know in some ways
this is an example of the artists
knowing the neuroscience before the
neuroscientists know the neuroscience
right like you know preusse was a
neuroscientist that way right so so yeah
I mean I think we've this is this is
actually why I sort of turned the whole
four cadence my podcast for this book in
particular to like turn the idea on its
head I don't want to use signs to reduce
music and you know take out all the
mystery and wonder of it I want to use
music to help me understand the brain
right humanity it's much more
interesting to me because I feel like
you know musicians and other artists
have been studying these aspects of
human behavior for so long that we can
learn so much from their observations of
what is successful and what is not about
ourselves and then those make like great
you know we can easily publishable
neuroscience research where you say oh
look you know here's the thing you know
artists have known for hundred years but
I you know and so I think it's really
important to actually look to artists
and you know so when people say like how
do you define music and my answer is
like ask your favorite artist to ask
your favorite musician because they will
have a much better idea of what it means
to have soul an idea of what it means to
you know create a good track versus a
mediocre track because they they know it
better than we do and you know it so I
think to me like we can the neuroscience
can maybe add a little bit but more
importantly I think that the art can can
help direct the neuroscience I mean I
completely agree but just to be
nitpicking here I do think that
sometimes people know
it broadly construed but can't say it
for sure that's a whole nother skill set
exactly and if for me it wasn't until I
actually saw the activation maps of the
caudate nucleus and the nucleus
accumbens that I understood what my
singing teacher was saying to me over
five years which is in Drey it's not the
high note that matters it's all the
notes leading up to the high note and I
was like you're wrong if I mess up I
know I'm not gonna get paid right and
but she was exactly right
and and because if the high note comes
out of nowhere first of all technically
that's really hard and it's not gonna
get as create a high note and to the
audience doesn't expect it and they
don't care about it just sounds weird
the journey nothing it's the journey
right and so like and it wasn't until I
literally saw this like beautiful graph
in a paper that showed how the dopamine
is tracked in the caudate first and then
gives this like chute and the nucleus
accumbens am I just do you okay
maybe other people we all get to the
destination in different ways does so I
guess you know just the final idea that
I wanted to ask about is the future of
music / the brain right you know one
idea that I've been fascinated by is
that we as a culture stopped
individually producing music because we
got recordings instead right you know
got records and we got radio and now we
have CDs and you sorry we don't see
these anymore we used to have CDs now we
have I just digital versions right
whatever they are right yeah iTunes is
the word I was looking for there but it
I get the impression that technology is
making it more possible to create music
in some interesting ways yeah I think
we're at a pivotal point and maybe
everybody says that about every decade
but you know I actually do feel like we
are at a pivotal point I think that we
are in danger of losing the amateur
music musician which i think would be
really tragic because I think we gain
the most out of actually participating
in music making we see that from babies
as early as six months and people as old
as 95 who you know come alive in the
nursing home when they get to make music
but you know the other side of it is is
that you're you're right that you know
we our lives are so busy we don't have
time to devote you know 10,000 hours to
learning to play the violin but we can
create
with our computers and you know in these
ways and it's it's easier than ever and
maybe with technologies like
neurostimulation we'll even be able to
enhance the ability to learn a new
musical instrument I don't know that's
still a big question mark but but I do
think that you know we you know we need
to kind of really be thoughtful about
how we approach music making and but I
think this is something that's that's
happening you know all over you know in
terms content creation everywhere like
you know you started your own podcast
right you know there are a lot of people
who create videos on YouTube and so you
have this like you know seemingly
endless amount of content that now it's
accessible to everyone and so curation
becomes really important but also so you
know I think that we can be
participatory in terms of how we curate
music maybe and maybe being a DJ is
exactly that curating sound and creating
new sound out of it as opposed to
creating your own sound kind of I mean
maybe some Peters will get mad at me for
that but um they're not playing
instruments in the same way right but
but but content creation comes in many
forms and I think everyone thinks they
can talk anyone can point a camera but I
think that there is a barrier and maybe
it's just mental maybe we should try to
overcome it to either performing or
composing new music yeah I mean I again
I think it depends on how you hat in how
society defines the musician and I think
up until now we've kind of gotten too
far down the line of you need to be a
professional musician you know you know
otherwise you shouldn't you shouldn't
even bother and I think that's really
unfortunate because I think in much of
human history that wasn't the case you
know I don't mean Jane Austen novels
someone was playing the piano every
night all the time it was part of your
education and you know if you think
about it like 10,000 years ago or 2,000
years ago like you know if you were
gonna make music it was around the fire
presumably everybody was a part of it
and I think that we if we lose that it's
gonna be harder to feel connected to
each other and in a kind of small way I
saw a software demonstration of this
thing that would basically a computer
program that would help you write a song
yeah and it actually sort of came up
with random things and you would pick
the ones that sounded good and it would
mix them together in a pleasant way I
mean cool but then has to still be
social right like
in your basement and creating music with
a computer I think it's just not
ultimately as powerful or motivating as
playing a garage band
and I think that we have to and I think
people gonna realize that look we're
adaptive as a species you know when
things go to swing the pendulum swings
too far in one direction we go somewhere
else
right so in terms of how we use social
media if it's making a SAP we're gonna
stop using it in ways that make us sad
so if we really miss making music
together we're gonna stop sitting in our
computers by ourselves creating you know
mp3 files and we're gonna go back into
the garage and pick up an instrument so
what do you think 100 years from now
will be the way that we appreciate music
uh Shawn sometimes I worry we're not
gonna be here is that condition alized
on survival of the species yeah I mean I
think probably I still suspect that we
will somehow find ways of being
physically in sync with each other to a
kind of rhythm and that melody will
still play a role and we'll you know
have time wouldn't a man maybe because
you know our robot overlords will allow
us to just spend all our days making
music okay so now we're gonna fade out
to a piece of music that was written by
a friend of mine from graduate school
who had a band and this is the theme
music for mindscape so it's a little bit
of a reminder that we should all be
creating a little bit of music as well
as appreciating andreas contests thanks
so much for being on the podcast thanks
John it's good to see you
[Music]